[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: If you've
ever felt like you've
had to make a trade-off
between great customer
support and
operational efficiency,
then Google Cloud's Contact
Center AI is for you.
Contact Center AI can
listen, understand,
and interact in a human-like
manner with your customers.
Contact centers have
a lot of moving parts,
and so does Contact Center AI.
So in this instructional
video, we'll
provide an overview
of the AI components
themselves and define
what our partner
solutions can offer
across a range
of operational environments.
We'll also touch on
the key requirements
for implementation.
Contact Center AI combines
four key ingredients,
enabling a conversation
that's close to human--
The conversational core, the
Virtual Agent, Agent Assist,
and insights.
Let's jump right in.
Google Cloud's
conversational core
is like a brain that
enables conversation.
It redefines the art of
AI-powered conversation
by providing a
close-to-human experience
through Google Cloud's
speech-to-text, a deep learning
neural network API that knows
precisely what customers mean,
regardless of their
accent, use of vocabulary,
or unique phrasing.
Text-to-speech responds
to your customer
in a natural, human-like
manner, allowing the customer
to push the conversation
along, avoiding frustration.
Google Cloud's Dialogflow
uses our world-class natural
language understanding to
identify your customer's intent
and determines the
appropriate next steps.
The conversational
core enables you
to provide a consistent,
high quality conversational
experience across channels and
platforms, human and virtual,
which leads us to
the Virtual Agent.
A good way to discuss
Google Cloud's Virtual Agent
architecture is to show an
experience we've all had.
Imagine you're the customer.
The conversational
experience begins.
When you initiate
your request, it's
received by Dialogflow,
which matches
the intent after
converting speech to text.
The AI also utilizes
optimized telephony models
for the language.
Dialogflow makes a
call to the back end,
using a web hook function
or other services
and receives a response.
This response is then converted
to speech using text-to-speech
and sent back to the user.
If your request requires a
deep knowledge-based query,
then the reply is received via
FAQ or a third party knowledge
based service in real
time, providing you
with a seamless
customer experience.
Sometimes a question will still
require live agent support.
And Google Cloud's Agent Assist
makes this process seamless
as well.
The call gets routed to an agent
through the partner telephony
channel.
A session manager monitors
the state of the conversation.
It sends the request to
a partner installed agent
desktop.
At this point, the
human agent will
see transcripts of
the conversation
with the Virtual Agent, which
saves the agent from having
to repeat questions.
Google Cloud's Contact Center
AI with its built-in natural
language understanding grabs
the context of the conversation
to suggest articles and real
time, step-by-step guidance
so the agent can help the
conversation move along.
The human agent is also provided
with smart replies on the Agent
Desktop.
Agents can also provide feedback
on the article suggestions
so the system can learn.
The conversation experience
is further enhanced
through the insights you'll
gain into your customer data,
including top call drivers
and associated sentiment.
You'll be able to upload data
in the form of voice and chat
transcripts that
are then converted
to text using speech-to-text.
Your insights become available
via a live dashboard showing
tons of stats like how many
calls are being received,
what is the percent split
amongst intents, and more.
Up to now, we've focused on the
components of Contact Center
AI.
Now, let's talk about how you'll
experience the ground game.
Robotic pre-recorded
voices will now
be human-like,
text-to-speech conversations
that are generated on the fly.
Rules-based fixed
hierarchy bots are now
AI-powered virtual agents.
Clunky speech transcriptions
requiring regular tuning
are now auto-tuned,
AI-driven speech models,
running on Google's own
neural network TPUs.
And searching knowledge
bases or memorizing shortcuts
will be a thing of the past
by surfacing relevant articles
and insights in real
time to human agents.
So now you're ready to start
your own implementation.
Google Cloud has partnered with
your existing telephony partner
to ensure the transition to
Contact Center AI is seamless.
We've done the technical heavy
lifting so you don't have to.
All you need to do is
enable the solution.
Telephony partners
are Google Cloud's
core go-to-market
exclusive sales channel,
with Cloud AI serving
as a critical component
in their solutions.
Desktop partners
provide the user
interface that the agent
uses while interacting
with the customer.
This interface receives
information from Dialogflow
and will display the transcript
and knowledge as it surfaces.
Knowledge partners synchronize
the contact center's content
into the customer's
knowledge bases,
providing the ability to
surface knowledge articles
and suggestions to human agents,
allowing Google Cloud's Contact
Center AI to provide
access to the customer's
corpus of information at
every agent's fingertips.
Contact Center AI will only
be available for purchase
through Google Cloud's
telephony partners.
However, systems
integration partners
will be utilized for
integrating Contact Center AI
components with the selected
telephony partner platform.
Systems integrators can also
offer complementary services
for on-boarding and
integration beyond what
the telephony partner offers.
Interested in taking the next
steps toward Contact Center AI?
Talk with your contact
center vendor or Google Cloud
representative to
discuss next steps
for implementing Google
Cloud's Contact Center
AI in your business.